تحدث وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكين
إلى شبكة CNN حول الخطوات التالية في
غزة قائلاً إنه بمجرد انتهاء الحرب على إسرائيل،
يتعين على غزة إيجاد
سلام دائم ومستدام، هذا ما قاله
لجيك تابر يوم
الأحد بالطبع يريد الجميع رؤية
هذه الحملة تأتي إلى  إغلاق في
أسرع وقت ممكن أه لكن أي دولة
تواجه ما تواجهه إسرائيل هي
منظمة إرهابية هاجمتها
بأفظع طريقة ممكنة في
7 أكتوبر وكما قلت لقد قلت مرارا
وتكرارا أنها ستفعل ذلك مرارا
وتكرارا وقد فعلت ذلك  لنصل إلى
النقطة التي أه واثق أن ذلك
لن يتكرر لكن
نقطة أخرى مهمة جدا عندما
تنتهي العملية العسكرية الكبرى أه هذا
لم ينته لأنه يجب أن يكون لدينا
سلام دائم دائم أه ولدينا
للتأكد من أننا نسير على الطريق المؤدي إلى
سلام دائم ومستدام من وجهة
نظرنا، أعتقد من وجهة نظر
الكثيرين حول العالم أه
يجب أن يؤدي ذلك إلى دولة فلسطينية، وهذا
يعني أننا لن نحظى بسلام دائم
لن يكون لدينا أمن دائم
لإسرائيل أه إلا وإلى أن
تتحقق التطلعات السياسية الفلسطينية أه وطبعا ما يحدث أه في
اليوم التالي في غزة نفسها بمجرد انتهاء
العمليات العسكرية العمليات العسكرية الكبرى
هذا عادة أيضا مهم أه
وعاجل  التأكد من أن
إعادة بناء أمن الحكم وكل ذلك
في مكانه حتى لا يكون هناك
فراغ